It's not good. He might
be. That's our mat. I um,
I bumped into someone's car once and I
left a note with my phone number and my,
uh, my address. Nice.
And, uh, not my address,
my phone number and my name and um,
they called me up and they
just so happened to be very
good friends with someone
who else friends with.
So then he calls me up and he tells me,
dude, you hit my friend's car. And then he
tells me, then I go tell him to call me.
Man. It's cool. Yeah,
it was undetectable. I,
it wasn't bad, but it was
something. Yeah know it was like,
it was a little scuff on the bumper,
but it was my, it was, I was like, oh,
thank God I left a message. I felt
like such a piece of shit up my friend.
And he was like,
and some fucking asshole hit
my friend's car and took off.
You believe that shit. I'm like, no.
Crazy Bro. That's, that's bullshit.
And now cameras have everybody doing
everything so you'll always get busted.
Yeah. When do you think it's going
to be where you have a Tesla,
you know with those things do when you
think it's going to be where no one's
driving. How many, how many
more years? We're, well,
we're a lot of people aren't driving 20
I would say 20 to 30 you remember when
Prius's were a joke?
Yeah.
Someone had a preach to like get that
fucking stupid thing away from me. Yeah.
Or even the early Tesla.
The roadster. Like,
do you know that top gear you want to,
you know that British show top gear?
Here's what's crazy.
I found out they did an episode where
they pretended that the Tesla roadster
died on them while they were
driving around the track.
But it didn't really die on though.
That was just the storyline was that
they wanted it to die. So that's gross.
Apparently the way the show is made,
it's like a comedy show and it's
scripted so they can get away with doing
something like that.
So Elon Musk's sued them
and I think he lost,
believe it or not, cause they
don't claim to be. Exactly.
They don't claim to be factual and they
complained, they, they, they don't,
they don't claim to not have narratives.
They create.
So gross that up just to make
sure that I'm bad. Grossly gross.
It's amazing how many shots that
they take. Elon Musk called top gear,
completely phony and his company
sued for libel and malicious falls.
So it's a judge dismissed the suit in
October saying no view or the program
could have reasonably be compared the
roadsters performance on the track to real
world performance on the street. That
seems fuzzy. I don't know what that means.
Okay. What is um, 2012
that way? What is the case?
What did he said?
What Elon Musk said that was that they
faked it and they claim the power Tesla.
Okay, let's see what it says.
We could figure out, I think,
I'm pretty sure that's the story.
After tests dropped the car off,
Elon Musk claim that one of his
employees was along for the delivery.
Notice that a script for the episode
inside there was a segment about the Tesla
breaking down,
but that was only the tip of the iceberg.
Top gear claim that the Tesla roadster
ran out of power while driving after just
55 miles, much less than the
200 miles quoted by Tesla,
albeit it was being driven hard.
A claim that must said was untrue.
According to him,
the roadsters logs show that the car
had never dipped below 20% charge during
the entirety of the filming.
The clip followed with the
roadsters motor overheating,
which wasn't addressed by mosque.
And finally a break failure,
which must claims was instead a blown
fuse and not an equipment failure.
Battery powered electric cars
will soon die altogether.
Former topcare host James
Mason. Ah, interesting.
Isn't that amazing?
So there were some,
it sounds like there was
some horseshit for sure,
but it does sound like there was a real
break problem and the brake problem was
a blown fuse, which there's
nothing you can do about that,
but just that it's such a
strange thing that like, yeah,
you just have to attack electric
cars. Like it's just a, well,
I think the wem them making a script.
If they had a script that said that
the test was going to break down,
they thought it was be funny.
It's a comedy bit.
It's a comedy show with Jeremy Clarkson
was fucking hilarious. He's really funny.
But there is definitely all
the people that are, yeah.
You believe a lot of the stuff that they
say and the performance of the car. I,
you know,
I always thought it was funny,
but I also saw them as experts.
Well, they kind of are.
Yeah. I mean, uh, they
know a lot of shit. Yeah.
They know a lot of shit about
cars, for sure. Jeremy Clarkson,
he knows a lot about cars.
The problem is people go to them for
advice and lap times and all that shit.
And if you're saying a car is breaking
down you, you engineered that script,
it's pretty dirty. That is dirty. Well,
that's how like Sean Hannity gets away
with saying that he's not a news program.
Does he get away with that? So it's like
WWT give news. Yeah. He says it's a,
it's a, it's entertainment. Really.
Yeah. Oh dude, that's hilarious. Way.
You have a little, a little out. We're
not a news program. We don't claim to be.
He says that. Yeah. Although
a lot of people are coming to,
to thinking that's news, but isn't
he, um, uh, commentary program?
Isn't that what they say?
Oh, he's not that. He's new.
He says it's entertainment.
Oh yeah. Do you find
entertaining? No. You should sue,
I should say. It's just so I could do,
besides this entertaining, he's a liar.
It's not that entertaining.
I didn't find it entertaining,
so I'm going to sue them.
And the game of Thrones people,
dragons.